je t'ai pas dit j'ai rencontré - surtout
des regrets une bouchère
je la vois on prend un petit café ou
je paye l'addition je rentre chez moi
qu'est-ce qu'elles n'envoient alors moi
ça c'est pas dingue
la meuf ramène des têtes de veau chez
zen mais pourquoi je sais pas
et je sais pas si ça m'excite aussi sam
desgouttes des violences make way cet
art est dur moi je suis plus utile
je sais que c'est un bug le même temps
j'ai un baroud
en tout cas comme je dis ça à votre
petite amie c'est pas possible de faire
un bruit pareil
moi j'ai des mutations n'y a aucun souci
mais après faut voir avec vincent par
culture là la mort quand il jouit des
mois bah non mais ça va pas je vous
rassure je je je jouis traoré ben
j'espère tout à l'heure ça suffit à
faire de nos jouets par un conseil
syndical donc le respect de vos voisins
oui ça m'intéresse au premier chef
et puis c'est pas parce que vous êtes à
peine à jouir monsieur qu'il faut en
garder tous les meubles ou là